[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers guten
abend inhalten wir müssen heute beginnen
mit der sorge vor einem neuen krieg im
osten europas russland hat an der grenze
zur ukraine militär verbände
zusammengezogen die weit größer sind als
die komplette heeres stärke der
bundeswehr nur um mal einen vergleich zu
haben dazu kommt ein ganzes arsenal
schwerer waffen und eine rhetorik aus
dem kreml die alles andere als
deeskalierend klingt die nato zeigt sich
alarmiert deutschland warnt russland vor
einem angriff auf die ukraine nun gab es
das im frühjahr schon mal mit etwa
derselben zahl russischer truppen und
dann passierte nichts umgekehrt hat
russland 2014 mit weit weniger truppen
die krim annektiert ist das aktuell also
eine drohgebärde oder besteht anlass zu
größter sorge der mann im kreml liefert
argumente für beide möglichen varianten
florian neumann berichtet von all den
hindernissen die sich der ukraine dieser
tage in den weg stellen ist der schnee
auf dem roten teppich in riga noch am
leichtesten zu beseitigen nato
außenministertreffen in lettland es
kommt der außenminister aus dem nicht
mitgliedsland ukraine und er hat eine
botschaft
wenn die ukraine in schwierigkeiten
gerät gerät die gesamte ostflanke der
nato in schwierigkeiten ein
nato-beitritt der ukraine ist
unausweichlich auch wenn er noch etwas
dauert die ukraine und die nato es ist
kompliziert 2008 verspricht das
westliche verteidigungsbündnis in
bukarest auf drängen des damaligen us
präsidenten george hw bush und zum ärger
russlands eines tages werde die ukraine
mitglied 13 jahre später ist sie immer
noch bloß gast dafür aber in
schwierigkeiten bedroht vom großen
nachbarn russland zumindest stellt sich
in riga ein us außenminister vor die
kameras und spricht von beweisen
unruhigen beweise zutiefst dass russland
erhebliche aggressive schritte gegen die
ukraine plant etwa die ukraine von innen
zu destabilisieren oder große
militäroperationen
offiziell bestreitet russland jede
kriegerischer absicht doch weil putin
2014 schon einmal mit der krim einem
teil der ukraine besetzte glaubt ihm das
so recht niemand was wladimir putin
nicht anficht heute verlangt er dass die
nato jegliche beitritts pläne der
ukraine ab sagt
[Musik]
im dialog mit den usa und ihren
alliierten werden wir auf einer
vereinbarung bestehen die jede
erweiterung der nato in den osten
ausschließt genau so wie die lieferung
von waffen in unsere nachbarschaft
frage an nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg in riga würde das denn die
lage entspannen sollte die nato sich aus
denen in russisches einflussgebiet
stoltenberg reagiert bei einer
aufbrausend
kosten allein die frage zeigt etwas was
für mich nicht akzeptabel ist
nämlich dass russland ein einfluss
gewittert russland hat kein veto rind
keine macht einen einflussgebiet zu
installieren indem es seine nachbarn zu
kontrollieren versucht
immerhin für morgen hat sich us
aussenminister blinken nun mit seinem
russischen kollegen lavrov zu einem
gespräch verabredet
währenddessen lassen beide seiten
öffentlich ihre militärischen muskeln
spielen die nato trainiert den
verteidigungsfall in lettland und
russland beginnt heute seien nach
eigenen angaben reguläres winter manöver
mit 10.000 soldaten teilweise auch an
der grenze zur ukraine
ja viele unterschiedliche eilmeldungen
warnungen drohungen wir versuchen da
jetzt mal ein bisschen ordnung
reinzubringen mit sarah packung sie es
bei der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik ihr fachgebiet dort
die außen und sicherheitspolitik
russlands guten damm verpackung wie
mulmig wird ihnen denn wenn sie das
sehen was da aktuell passiert zwischen
russland und der ukraine
wir müssen schon sagen dass eine
militärische eskalation an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze durchaus
ein realistisches szenario ist wir sehen
über wochen einen aufbau von
militärische personal aber auch von
einsatzfähigen waffensystem auf
russischer seite und die schon geeignet
sind um eine teil in versionen der
ukraine durchzuführen das heißt
natürlich nicht zwingend dass diese
entscheidung und moskau schon gefallen
es ist wahrscheinlich eher eine art
strategie des vortasten bei der geschaut
wird nicht nur wie kiew reagiert sondern
auch für die nato und vor allen dingen
die usa reagieren aber es wäre möglich
verstehe ich sie so dass es zu einer
teil in version kommen könnte jetzt kann
ja sicherheitspolitik verpackung nicht
immer nur vom prinzip hoffnung leben
muss vielleicht sogar erst mal vom
negativsten möglichen szenario ausgehen
was hat wladimir putin vor das ist die
große frage die wir heute nicht klären
werden aber was könnte dann aus
russischer sicht dafür sprechen in die
ukraine einzumarschieren also wenn wir
uns anschauen was die russischen ziel in
osteuropa und vor allen dingen auch in
der ukraine über die letzten jahre waren
müssen wir feststellen dass viele der
politischen ziele nicht erreicht worden
also wir sehen zum einen dass die
sanktionen nicht abgebaut wurden sondern
sie werden anders bezogen sogar
erweitert die beziehungen mit kiew sind
frostig auch unter dem präsidenten
selensky und letztendlich strebt die
ukraine sei 2013 eine west integration
nicht nur in die eu und sondern auch in
die nato an und unabhängig davon wie
realistisch das mittelfristig ist sieht
russland das eben zum einen als
bedrohung aber zum anderen auch als
scheitern seiner eigenen politischen
ziele mit diplomatischen mitteln und die
frage ist eben inwiefern russland dann
setzt auch auf militärische mittel setzt
und wenn wir das jetzt mal von der
anderen von der russischen seite aus
betrachten was ist dran an russischen
befürchtungen gegenüber der ukraine
russland sagt er jetzt aktuell
die ukraine habe die halbe armee in den
osten des landes verlegt
also das würde ich eher für eine
rechtfertigung strategie von russischer
seite halten auch mit blick darauf dass
der also diese begründung ja von frau
sacherer war kommen der
außenamtssprecherin russland sieht
durchaus für spitze kommentare bekannt
dass ich glaube das problem für russland
sind nicht etwaige truppenbewegungen
sondern die militärische kooperation
zwischen der ukraine und der nato die
russland als bedrohung sieht das ist
eigentlich eher der kern des problems
gut da reden doch jetzt mal darüber was
zu tun ist um diese situation halbwegs
in den griff zu bekommen wir haben es
gerade eben beitrag gesehen die
nato-außenminister sitzen zusammen eine
krisensitzung nach der anderen was
würden sie denn jetzt empfehlen zu tun
also es gibt vor allen dingen zwei
sachen jetzt passieren müssen das eine
ist natürlich eine wirkungsvolle
abschreckung das hat die nato versucht
auch mit der androhung von sanktionen
man muss leider sagen dass man hier sehr
vage geblieben ist man hat nur von
schwerwiegenden wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen sanktionen gesprochen ohne
weiter auszuführen was das wirklich
beinhalten sollte auch hinsichtlich
einer erweiterten militärischen
kooperation auch waffenlieferungen ist
sich die allianz nicht einig
andererseits gilt es natürlich schon
bestimmte dialog kanäle offen zu halten
das betrifft vor allen dingen die
aktuellen verhandlungen der usa mit
russland im bereich cyber sicherheit
aber auch strategische rüstungskontrolle
und nicht zuletzt auch das von russland
geforderte treffen zwischen beiden und
putin
militärische drohungen der nato sind
undenkbar aus ihrer sicht der völliger
wahnsinn oder wäre das tatsächlich auch
ein mittel das ist das ist in der
allianz sondern aktuell nicht
mehrheitsfähig also wir sehen zwar
beispielsweise us amerikanische
waffenlieferungen an der ukraine habe
viele der allianz mitglieder teilen
diese ansicht nicht einfach an auch
deutschland die frage ist natürlich ob
sich das ändern würde im falle einer
russischen invasion der ukraine aber
auch sicherlich würde es hier nicht
weiter als waffenlieferungen gehen denn
letztlich ist die ukraine kein nato
mitglied dann bleiben also noch
drastischere wirtschaftssanktionen wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt das gebiet der
nato da ist ja dann vielleicht eher die
europäische union gefordert und auch
deutschland natürlich das mit russland
ja das umstrittene pipeline projekt nord
stream 2 durch zieht nach wie vor liegt
an dieser stelle möglicherweise der
entscheidende einfluss also das wären
sicherlich die stärksten mitte die die
westliche allianz oder auch die eu dann
noch auf zu bieten hätte vor allen
dingen wenn wir beispielsweise einen
ausschluss anpfiff systemdenken auch
eine verstärkte sanktionen gegenüber
russischen staat schulden und russischen
banken und industrie um zwei muss dann
in jedem fall zurück auf den tisch dann
die deutsche bundesregierung hat sich
auch im sommer nochmals dazu
verpflichtet die territoriale integrität
und souveränität der ukraine zu
unterstützen und dann ist es schon zwei
wenn wir deutschland isoliert betrachten
sich ja nicht der größte hebel den wir
haben wenn wir natürlich von gaza
-aktion absehen aber ich glaube das ist
nicht auf dem tisch ganz kurzen
verpackung wie groß ihre befürchtung
dass jetzt irgendjemand auf irgendeiner
seite in dieser aufgeheizten stimmung
einen fehler macht und die lage dann
nicht mehr zu kontrollieren ist ich
würde sagen das ist ein reales risiko
auch wenn wir sehen mit welchem massive
truppenpräsenz russland dort an der
grenze zu gegen ist auch wenn wir uns
anschauen wie also wie die beziehung
zwischen den separatisten im donbass und
moskau ist das einfach auch das
potenzial von unkontrollierbaren und von
unwägbaren situationen durchaus
vorhanden herzlichen dank für diese
erläuterungen heute abend im
heute-journal sarah packung von der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik danke nach berlin
und damit ihr bei uns jetzt zu dem
dauerthema dass unsere krankenhäuser
unsere politik und nicht zuletzt unsere
gemüter belastet und das bereits in der
x-ten wiederauflage wir wissen alle
morgen ist der tag an dem neue
einschränkungen des täglichen lebens
kommen werden der versuch mitten in der
vierten welle diese irgendwie zu bremsen
verschiedene bundesländer preschen jetzt
bereits vor andere zögern manche fordern
dass der bund ins boot muss so seine
freitag berichtet
geschwitzt wird hier ab morgen nur noch
mit 2g plus wer nicht getestet ist kommt
nicht rein selbst wenn er eine booster
impfung hat dabei sei die
ansteckungsrate in fitnessclubs doch
sehr gering sagt besitzer marco wolter
der stimmt derzeit aktenordner mit
miesen kurve bilanzen jetzt muss er
schnell personal besorgen für die
kontrollen und viele kunden werden
wegbleiben zu hoch der aufwand noch dazu
kommt dass man mittlerweile weiß dass
regelmäßiges training das publikum über
70 prozent reduziert das hat sogar karl
lauterbach zitiert diese studie und dass
dann der politik nach zwei jahren nichts
anderes einfällt als den zugang zu
gesundheitstraining viele leute nochmal
so extrem zu erschweren und das ist für
uns natürlich später enttäuschend das
saarland verschärft schon vor der
konferenz der ministerpräsidenten
masken pflicht überall wo
mindestabstände nicht möglich sind aus 2
g.de 2g plus tests in restaurants hotels
kinos und kultur clubs und diskotheken
müssen schließen und in schulen müssen
auch geimpfte schüler und lehrer
getestet werden kontakt beschränkungen
gelten für ungeimpfte sie dürfen nur
noch eine person aus einem anderen
haushalt treffen im einzelhandel geht
zweig ausgenommen geschäfte der
grundversorgung und da sieht die branche
ein problem was ist überhaupt
grundversorgung wer gehört dazu wer
gehört nicht dazu und wenn die einen
zweig haben darauf die läuft die
kundschaft natürlich zu den großen
filialisten zum großflächigen handel und
die kleinen die sehen dann wieder ja alt
aus in diesem sport geschäft haben sie
schon den lockdown im ski land
österreich deutlich gespürt jetzt kommt
auch noch die 2g regel dazu sie fürchten
umsatzeinbußen
das schlimmste was uns passieren kann
dass wir einen kunden der offensichtlich
gerne unser haus besuchen möchte den
zugang verweigern schlimmer geht es ja
gar nicht aber andererseits ist es so
wenn wir mal aus diesem kreislauf des
schließens öffnen schließen öffnen
wieder rauskommen wollen dann bleibt uns
nichts anderes übrig faktisch gilt im
saarland ein lockdown für ungeimpfte das
schwierig
[Musik]
jedenfalls vielleicht auch schon lange
aber komplett ausschließen finde ich
sehr hart bekannte die sind auch nicht
geimpft ja ich denke als jedem seine
entscheidung impfung als eintrittskarte
hier in hamburg ist die nachfrage nach
erst- und nach booster impfungen enorm
gestiegen es gibt zu wenig impfstoff
auch hessen und berlin beklagen mängel
es gab probleme beim bestellen aber
nicht nur das plötzlich ankündigungen
des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums in diese
situation hinein kommen dass also der
impfstoff kontingentiert werden muss das
stößt auch hier auf großes unverständnis
impfstoffmangel hier streit über
maßnahmen dar morgen will man
bundesweite mindeststandards festlegen
die vierte welle soll gebrochen werden
so einheitlich wie möglich
janna gucken wir von dem was einzelne
länder schon tun auf das was morgen für
ganz deutschland beschlossen werden soll
da gibt es noch nicht sämtliche details
da gibt es natürlich auch noch keine
beschlüsse aber eine beschlussvorlage
und die geht in eine klare richtung
schock unterlagen amt ja tatsächlich ist
das eine klare richtung wenn der text
dann so bleibt wir in diesem entwurf
drin steht und zwar heißt diese richtung
bundeseinheitliche verschärfungen der
maßnahmen dazu gehört dann zum beispiel
zweig für freizeiteinrichtungen also
theaters kinos und restaurants aber auch
den einzelhandel mit ausnahme von
geschäften des täglichen bedarfs in
beide dürften dann ungeimpfte nicht mehr
rein sondern nur noch geimpfte und
gelesene personen es soll auch sehr viel
strengere kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte personen geben nämlich dann
dürfen sich dort nur noch ein haushalt
mit zwei weiteren personen aus einem
anderen haushalt treffen ausgenommen
sind kinder unter 14
und auch eine masken pflicht für schulen
steht drin eine bundesweite und zwar
auch für alle klassenstufen also das ist
schon nochmal ein deutliches anziehen
der maßnahmen es gibt aber auch noch
diskussionsbedarf das sehen wir in
diesem entwurf auch zum beispiel bei
großveranstaltungen da ist noch nicht
klar oder die obergrenze für
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sein soll
sowohl in innenräumen als auch im freien
also zum beispiel bei fußballspielen und
auch bei der instanz für die schließung
von clubs und diskotheken ist noch nicht
klar ab welchem wert denn diese
einrichtungen schließen sollten also es
wird morgen noch gespräche geben
aber dass da ein entwurf rauskommt der
einrichtung schärfere maßnahmen geht das
ist schon klar jetzt hast du chocolat zu
recht darauf hingewiesen dass es sich
bislang um eine beschlussvorlage handelt
wie viel einigkeit ist morgen zu
erwarten also man muss sagen dass es
wahrscheinlich in den letzten zwei
jahren selten so viel demonstrativer
harmonie vor einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gegeben hat
wie diesmal parteiübergreifend sagen
alle da will man gemeinsam arbeiten und
man muss auch schauen dass es mehr
bundeseinheitlich kite gibt und es gab
ja auch gestern das vortreffen eine
video-konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten mit angela merkel
und olaf scholz da ist vieles von dem
was in diesem in diesem entwurf drin
steht schon vorbesprochen worden
deswegen ist die chance sehr groß dass
es dann auch sehr ähnlich am ende
ausgeht wie es jetzt drin steht wir
werden morgen ausführlich berichten
konter für heute herzlichen dank nach
berlin
3g regel hier zweig regel dort das sind
so schlagworte geworden in der
politischen diskussion und auch bei uns
im nachrichtengeschäft aber das hat ja
ganz konkrete folgen und das hinterlässt
spuren
zigtausendfach jeden tag in deutschland
anselm stern zeigt in seiner reportage
jetzt den komplizierten alltag in einem
kleinen niedersächsischen unternehmen in
dem wie überall am arbeitsplatz 3 gilt
so startet arnold schmitt in den
arbeitstag in jeden arbeitstag halb
sechs am morgen corona abstrich unter
aufsicht arnold schmitt ist nicht
geimpft
das ist der hauptgrund warum hast du
bisher nicht impfen lassen neben und wir
können wir erstens zweitens keiner sagt
dass er geschützt ist oder kann kein und
stecken es ist das gleiche prinzip
umgehender umgehend erkannt das gleiche
verbreitung und kann das gleiche kriegen
auch arnold sohn jaroslaw arbeitet hier
auch er nicht geimpft insgesamt sieben
von etwa 30 mitarbeitern haben keinen
impfschutz sie alle dürfen ohne
negativen test nicht zu den kollegen der
eine geschäftsführer überwacht die neue
pandemie routine während der andere
versucht die ungeimpften vom impfen zu
überzeugen die volkswirtschaft unser
betrieb da hält es aus wenn wir jetzt
wiederholt immerhin lockt uns kommen wir
das geht einfach nicht alle tests sind
negativ an diesem morgen arnold und die
anderen können loslegen das kleine
unternehmen in einbeck in niedersachsen
baut treppen die krise hat spuren
hinterlassen im betrieb und bei der
betriebs stimmung der impfstatus spaltet
die belegschaft
also es ist natürlich schon so ein
bisschen sonne zwei gruppenbildung gar
wir tun alles mögliche in gesprächen
eben um den dialog aufrecht zu erhalten
ich denke das gelingt uns auch ganz gut
vorbei wir schon auch immer wieder mal
hören wenn ich habe das gefühl die
setzen sich nicht mehr mit mir am tisch
hin weil ich unbedingt hin und soja das
existiert auch auf montage rené wenzel
bereitet alles vor für die arbeit bei
den kunden kundenkontakt hat er jeden
tag jeder der kann sollten geimpft sein
fordert er
also mit drum rumreden mit
wir brauchen 3g und dies dass das
einfache wort ist im pflicht wenn das
geschehen würde dann wäre die sache doch
erledigt
gegen masern muss man sich auch für
impfen lassen das ist einfach so also in
pflicht mehr sage ich nicht weil der
druck wächst die einschränkungen immer
größer werden will er sich jetzt nun
vielleicht doch impfen lassen sagt uns
arnold schmitt noch einen termin bei
seinem hausarzt gäbe es aber erst wieder
im februar
ja und dann ist da noch die omikron
variante was wir dazu wissen und was wir
dringend noch wissen müssten dazu mehr
nachher im heute-journal update und auch
das auslandsjournal direkt nach und
schaut genau hin wie diese virus
variante die welt in schrecken versetzt
und südafrika ins abseits stellt aber
erst hier bei uns in der sendung ein
erster nachrichtenüberblick und den hat
kaiser wird und da bleiben wir beim
thema eu
kommissionspräsidenten von der leyen
präsidiert für eine eu-weite debatte
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht nur
zwei drittel der einwohner seien geimpft
daher sei es angebracht über eine
verpflichtung nachzudenken es brauche
einen gemeinsamen ansatz die
entscheidung liege aber allein bei den
mitgliedstaaten
der biontech impfstoff für 5 bis 11
jährige wird bereits eine woche früher
ausgeliefert als angekündigt am 13
dezember sollen die ersten 24 millionen
dosen ankommen das bestätigte
gesundheitsminister sparen die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde hatte
die verwendung vergangene woche
genehmigt die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission steht aber noch aus
in zehn jahren könnte es rund eine
million pflegebedürftige mehr geben als
bisher angenommen auf dem barmer
pflegereport steigt die zahl der
betroffenen bis 2030 auf knapp 6
millionen an um sie angemessen zu
versorgen seien mehr als 180000
zusätzliche pflegekräfte nötig
deutschland steuert damit auf einen
dramatischen pflegenotstand zu der
jährliche finanzbedarf werde sich von
derzeit 49 auf 59 milliarden euro
erhöhen
in münchen ist ein blindgänger aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg explodiert dabei
wurden vier menschen verletzt einer von
ihnen schwer die 250 kilo bombe
detonierte bei bauarbeiten in der nähe
des hauptbahnhofs an einer der
meistbefahrenen bahnstrecken europas
sämtliche züge wurden gestoppt am
nachmittag rollte der verkehr dann
langsam wieder an
ein jahr nach der amokfahrt in trier
haben die menschen dort an die opfer
erinnert nicht nur die stadt sei damals
ins mark getroffen worden sondern das
ganze land sagte die
rheinland-pfälzische ministerpräsident
in drei jahren sie war zusammen mit
angehörigen betroffenen und ersthelfern
in dem trierer dom gekommen am ersten
dezember 2020 war ein autofahrer durch
die fußgängerzone gerast fünf menschen
kamen dabei ums leben dutzende wurden
verletzt einer von ihnen starb im
oktober
man darf annehmen dass die meisten
cdu-mitglieder ziemlich genau wissen wer
friedrich merz ist wer norbert röttgen
und wer helge braun märz etwa bringt
seine ideen für den parteivorsitz
mittlerweile im dritten anlauf unter die
leute vermutlich weiß er selbst nicht
mehr so genau wie viele video chats
regionalkonferenzen und townhall
meetings er in dieser sache bereits
absolviert hat aber da seine partei
schon wieder einen neuen chef braucht
und märz schon wieder antritt war heute
abend eine neue diskussionsrunde
angesetzt die durchaus spannung
versprach denn die partei muss das
historische desaster der bundestagswahl
aufarbeiten sich komplett neu sortieren
und zwar erst mal nicht mit der aussicht
auf weiteres regieren sondern auf harte
zeiten in der opposition nicole diekmann
hat mehr dazu
wer steht wo und wer steht wo für
einzeln haben sich die bewerber um den
cdu-vorsitz schon vorgestellt nun also 3
unter der überschrift wer bekommt die
angeschlagene cdu wie wieder auf kurs
ich möchte dass das aufhört dass aus
diesen sitzungen live berichterstattung
in der bild -zeitung stattfindet ich
werde in den sitzungen darum bitten dass
alle ihre handys draußen lassen und dass
wir mal wieder vertraulich und
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten
wir haben verschiedene wurzeln soziale
wurzeln liberale wurzeln und
konservativen wurzeln
das müssen wir als stärke begreifen so
wie früher für die cdu gleichzeitig
träger und und geißler gestanden haben
und irgendwie hatten alle das gefühl
dass es trotzdem eine starke cdu wer ist
denn der heiner geißler von heute also
personen die für unterschiedliche
inhalte gestanden haben und miteinander
gerungen haben ich glaube dass wir das
nicht mehr haben das ist ein fehler von
uns rom 25 cdu mitglieder die sich vorab
mit ihren fragen beworben hatten
stellten diese nun bezahlbares wohnen
frauenförderung digitalisierung
thematisch ging es quer durch den garten
und natürlich auch um das thema klima
ist eine die abfrage des klimaschutz ist
jetzt hinter uns und jetzt geht es um
die frage wer kann es denn besser und
ich nehme für uns in anspruch dass wir
die beste kompetenteste klima partei in
deutschland mindestens werden würden wir
wert werden wollen und werden die
stellen reden ständig darüber wo er
überall aussteigen aus der kernenergie
aus der steinkohle aus der braunkohle
wenn möglich jetzt auch demnächst noch
aus der aus der gasverstromung das ist
mir ein bisschen zu viel aufsteigt wir
müssen wir wieder darüber reden wo wir
eigentlich einsteigen wollen wenn wir
das in unserer industrie die ersten sind
die die technologien beherrschen wie zum
beispiel einer stahlindustrie die mit
wasserstoff arbeitet dann können wir
diese technologien in die welt
exportieren leisten damit einen beitrag
dafür dass auch andere länder ihren co2
abdruck verbessern und trotzdem so zu
sagen bleibt deutschland
exportweltmeister und mert auch seinen
wohlstand anderthalb stunden lang
standen die drei im kreis über kreuz
lagen sie nicht offener streit schadet
auch das ist eine lehre aus dem
verlorenen wahlkampf lieber kalte man
deshalb gegen die spd aus und gegen die
ampel als gegeneinander
und auch die afg kam zur sprache
wir müssen ganz sensibel mit der frage
umgehen dass wenn wir uns mit der afg
auseinandersetzen dass wir wirklich auf
die wähler abziehen und nicht durch die
auseinandersetzung mit der fdp die
wähler verschrecken die wir eigentlich
wieder zurück bekommen wollen wir
brauchen wieder mehr präsenz von
politikern west spitzenpolitikern in den
neuen ländern dort ist die
gesellschaftspolitische parteipolitische
konfrontation eine ganz andere da ist
die afg der gegner und die müssen wir
hart bekämpfen
kompromisslose ablehnung einer
zusammenarbeit mit der ard
ich sage das gerade weil sie aus
thüringen kommen so etwas was uns da
passiert ist wird sich unter meinem
vorsitz nicht wiederholen ab dem vierten
dezember können die cdu mitglieder
abstimmen wer steht für erneuerung für
zukunft für hoffnung das ergebnis gibt
es dann am 17 dezember
und was es jetzt gibt sind noch mal
wichtige verbraucher nachrichten von
kaseya denn heute ist das neue
telekommunikationsgesetz in kraft
getreten damit haben verbraucher ab
sofort mehr rechte zum beispiel müssen
wir nur noch für die
internetgeschwindigkeit zahlen die sie
auch tatsächlich bekommen und werde es
eine störung gibt muss sie innerhalb von
zwei arbeitstagen beseitigt werden
außerdem dürfen sich telefon internet
und mobilfunk verträge nicht mehr
automatisch um längere zeiträume
verlängern stattdessen kann man sie nach
ende der mindestlaufzeit monatlich
kündigen
in der türkei steigen die preise schon
länger rasant die teuerungsrate lag
zuletzt bei 20 prozent trotzdem will
präsident erdogan weiter die zinsen
senken und das hat die türkische lira
weiter auf talfahrt geschickt experten
warnen vor dramatischen folgen frank
bethmann was genau steht zu befürchten
im schlimmsten fall droht irgendwann die
zahlungsunfähigkeit also die pleite des
landes so weit ist es aber noch nicht
doch der anhaltende wertverlust der
lehrer weckte erinnerungen an die
schwere türkische finanzkrise im jahr
2001 damals gingen etliche banken pleite
gegenüber dem dollar hat die türkische
lira seit jahresanfang
rund 60 prozent an wert verloren die
geldentwertung trifft kleinverdiener und
mittelschichtler gleichermaßen
ausgerechnet erdogans wählerklientel die
preise für wohnraum und lebensmittel
steigen so stark an dass sich viele
türken auf den wochenmärkten nur noch
einen halben blumen oder weißkohl
leisten können die türkei gehört zu den
großen volkswirtschaften sie ist vom
importieren wie energie rohstoffen oder
arzneimitteln abhängig die aber unter
der ins bodenlose stürzen den lehrer
immer teurer werden heute stimmte sich
die zentralbank mit dem verkauf von
devisen gegen den verfall wohl eher eine
verzweiflungstat erdogan will mit weiter
fallenden leitzinsen die wirtschaft
ankurbeln einfach damit aber eine immer
gefährlicher werdenden geldentwertung
hierzulande will man die zunehmende
inflation wenn überhaupt mit steigenden
zinsen verhindern erdogan glaubt dass
der entgegengesetzten weg zum erfolg
führt mancher ökonom schüttelt darüber
den kopf
die damen tennis tour wdr hat sämtliche
turniere in china und hongkong
ausgesetzt wegen der unklaren situation
um die chinesische spielerin vom 2 sie
werde anscheinend unter druck gesetzt
und könne nicht frei kommunizieren
deshalb könne man die athleten nicht mit
gutem gewissen bitten in china
anzutreten jesus zur begründung porsche
hatte dem früheren regierungsvize lang
vorgeworfen sie sexuell missbraucht zu
haben
wichtiger hinweis noch zum wetter in
norddeutschland ist in diesen stunden
obacht geboten der deutsche wetterdienst
warnt an den küsten vor orkanartigen
sturmböen und noch kurz die lottozahlen
wie immer ohne gewähr
58 12 13 34 49 super 27 weiter
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
und damit bedankten wir zwei uns im
namen des gesamten heute schon mal teams
für ihr interesse und empfehlen ihnen
noch das heute-journal update mit
nacktem er um viertel vor eins
angenehmer abend
[Musik]
guten abend sturmtief daniel wird morgen
weiter nach osten ziehen bevor das
nächste tief zu uns kommt wird es erst
mal kälter also geht der regen schon
langsam wieder in schnee über aber das
wird weder viel regen noch viel schnee
dafür gibt es sehr viel wind heute abend
drohen immer noch orkanböen an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee vielleicht
auch noch in den mittelgebirgen und an
der nordsee reicht es vielleicht sogar
für eine kleine sturmflut das sturmtief
daniel sieht morgen weiter nach osten
und dann wird es kälter sie sehen wie
hier die regenfälle immer mehr in schnee
übergehen zunächst in den mittelgebirgen
bis zum abend aber auch in
süddeutschland schon heute nacht schneit
es im nördlichen schleswig holstein
sonst sind noch etliche schauer
unterwegs und am kältesten wird es in
nordfriesland da sinken die temperaturen
bis minus 1 grad sonst geht's auf plus 4
bis 0 grad runter unter diesen werten
ändert sich tagsüber wenig die werte
liegen dann zwischen 2 und 6 grad ja und
am freundlichsten ist es morgen hier in
einem streifen ungefähr zwischen den
lausitz und sylt richtung nordosten
allerdings fällt vor allen dingen am
vormittag noch schnee in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch im nördlichen
brandenburg es sind winter gewitter
unterwegs hier in ostfriesland auch im
emsland sonst gibt es etliche schauer
mit schnee mit regen und zum teil auch
mit schneeregen und zwischendurch sehen
sie aber doch auch häufiger die sonne
noch häufiger sehen sie die sonne dann
am freitag in süddeutschland bei minus
ein bis plus fünf grad das zweite
adventswochenende wird dann allerdings
schon wieder deutlich schmuddeliger
schönen abend